sur ces images fournies par l'armée
ukrainienne les soldats pénètrent dans
la ville d'izum il trouve des tanks
frappés de la lettre Z du matériel
militaire et de la nourriture les
troupes russes viennent de fuir dans la
précipitation
à 50 km à la cliente le drapeau jaune et
bleu flotte de nouveau
[Musique]
et l'euphorie s'est emparée des rues
honnêtement nous ne nous y attendions
pas quand j'ai vu les nôtres les soldats
Ukrainiens arrivaient avec leurs
écussons avec le drapeau oh c'était
génial
nous sommes très très heureux de
l'émotion beaucoup d'émotion
trois villes clés de la région de
carquis font été reprises à l'armée
russe en moins de 48 heures
environ 2000 km² de notre territoire ont
été libérés dans le cadre des opérations
actives depuis le début du mois de
septembre ces jours-ci l'armée russe
montre ce qu'elle fait de mieux montrer
son dos et partir en courant
après avoir enregistré des succès dans
le sud autour de Carson les Ukrainiens
revendiquent de nombreuses prises dans
le nord-est celle de coupiance et dizium
son stratégiques elle permettent de
perturber l'une des routes que l'armée
russe s'emprunte pour se rendre dans le
don-basse face à cette contre-offensive
et Claire l'état-major russe s'adapore
envoyer des renforts avant d'annoncer un
repli pour atteindre les objectifs de
l'opération de libération du don-basse
il a été décidé de regrouper les forces
russes déployées dans les régions de
malakia et dizium afin de renforcer nos
efforts sur le front de Donets plutôt le
chef de l'administration prorus disium
avait décrit une situation difficile à
cause de bombardements effectués avec
des lance-missiles fournies par les
États-Unis lors d'une visite surprise
dans la capitale la ministre allemande
des Affaires étrangères à elle annonçait
que Berlin continuerait à envoyer des
armes à l'Ukraine